trouver de l'aide ailleurs
maintenant que des dizaines de bénévoles
plus âgés doivent rester confinées à la
maison pour se protéger c'est le défi de
250 service alimentaire et celui de
moisson montréal qui les approvisionnent
les mêmes que la récupération des
ressources humaines que nous pourrions
avoir ici aujourd'hui les ondes et les
autres chiens ont des impôts y sont
nerveuses ou s'il faut que prendre soin
de sa peau y pleut bénévoles pour leur
assurer un environnement paille qui est
sécuritaire et on a tout réorganiser les
plateaux pour éloigner les gens
s'assurer qu'ils aient au moins deux
mètres entre chacun des individus
il y a un noyau dur de bénévoles mais
aussi des nouveaux venus
j'ai 17 ans et j'ai plus rien à faire
puis mais j'ai des coups mais il
commence le 30 mars
donc pourquoi pas prendre le temps pour
aider les autres et et fermer quoi en
fait le fait qu'on travaille pour les
jeunes pour leur donner un petit coup de
pouce ça vient vraiment ne cherche aucun
l'organisme a eu du renfort de la ville
de montréal qui a mis à sa disposition
les bras d'une dizaine d'inspecteurs du
service des incendies pour toute la
semaine on sait que les demandes des
deux vont exploser
alors aujourd'hui ce qu'on a décidé de
faire est bien c'est de vraiment se
joindre aux efforts de centraide afin de
soutenir vraiment les actions qui
permettent aux organismes de répondre
aux besoins de première nécessité
le fonds d'urgence nous permet aussi
d'accroître sa capacité d'action avec
plus de personnel et aussi de leur
donner l'équipement nécessaire pour
répondre aux nombreux appels qu'ils
reçoivent qui ont triplé certains
épiciers ont été pris d'assaut par des
citoyens plus nombreux avec c'est sûr
que si les égyptiens ont vidé la
tablette mais il reste à nous donner
mais la direction de moisson montréal ne
s'inquiète pas trop de ces soubresauts
convaincu que les grands fournisseurs
lui resteront fidèles et que de nouveaux
se manifesteront comme pour les
bénévoles
on essaie de faire attention
le fait d'être raisonnable et en même
temps faut continuer à vivre et à aider
ce pharmacien qui a vendu son commerce
avant la pandémie veut se rendre utile
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
mon